were you there when he lost all that
money gambling with jay-z and everybody
yeah i was in the crap yeah
i was like i mean we gamble we blackjack
yeah but that [ __ ] hurt my heart yeah we
all got like because i know he's got it
but uh i don't know who got it but he
like real blackjack players no i get it
i get it but i'm just saying that one
specific i don't know if it was a hand
or was it a bro was it it was a relay i
think he was no it was blackjack and i
think he was at like 16 in a dealership
like 13.
so he didn't hit he hit oh he did hit
and that's where we always like like we
play blackjack him cmgb me like
this [ __ ] is like strategy like we all
got our own strategy so for i think me
and cmgb was there
we were kind of looking at you like what
the [ __ ] did you just hit on the 16 for
i was sick for my boy though i would i
was sick i saw that [ __ ] i said and he
just was like
he yeah cause he ain't gonna ever show
you like oh i'd be [ __ ] i [ __ ]
when he got to the table though it was
one of the things like what the [ __ ]
what were you doing he was like i don't
know
i think it was that's usually how it
goes when you're in vegas and you are
down a bunch you're just like [ __ ]
yeah i didn't see him like wipe out
vegas though too oh i'm sure yeah i
didn't see him anybody who's willing to
gamble that much on one hand has also
won
no i didn't seem like sequino like when
the men in black come stand behind you
like it's it's two up like
yeah i didn't see any guy like the palms
there we own that we own the pond yeah
we're no part of that
i've gambled so much money away
especially on sports
oh yeah i don't do sports again sports
betting yeah it's wild